it's halftime both teams are listening  to a Madonna performance that sounds  eerily similar to a lady Gaga song  they'll hear 10 years from now it's  halftime in America two people are out  of work and they're hurting and they're  wondering where all their money went  well 12.5 billion dollars of it went to  Chrysler a form of a bailout but it's  okay because Chrysler's all American  though technically 58.5% of Chrysler's  owned by an Italian corporation and  Chrysler manufactures many of its  vehicles in Canada Mexico but I guess  that doesn't make for a great commercial  unlike polar bears our dogs our  digestive yogurt yet Americans are  hurting and their dollars are being used  to bailout the chosen ones instead of  themselves what happened to freedom what  happened to choice yeah we need to guard  them like Ben Roethlisberger's friend  guards a bathroom door allegedly